When it comes to the tools available in Engine for your control rig, let's take a look at
some of the functions and control types that can be useful when you're building a mechanical
rig.
Very often you'll find that something mechanical will contain a piston, whether this is part
of an engine, or a large rubber arm, or just there to support the movement in some other
way.
And for these scenarios, there is a function built into the engine called the piston function.
And that acts as a two-way aim constraint, allowing two elements of the rig, so bones
or controls or nulls, to always be pointing towards one another.
So if each end of the piston is anchored to a different mesh, say for example like the
upper and lower leg of a robotic character, this function will enable those pieces to
stay anchored where they are, and then always aim towards one another, maintaining that
functionality of the piston.
Something else that's useful is the FK chain function.
Now this is for a basic forward kinematic setup, where you just need a control to drive
the movement of a bone.
But something great about this is you can actually filter out different translation and rotation
axes, and just have it moving in one direction or rotating in one direction if that's what
you need.
When it comes to more complex robotic arms or legs, you might have something like a mechanical
arm that you're using on an assembly line, for example.
And for this you could use the IK3 bone function, which is a great way to get those moving where
you need precise movement for the end bone in the chain, maybe it's a claw picking something
up on an assembly line, and you need the rest of the arm to calculate its movement automatically.
And when it comes to dynamic movement for your mesh, so this would be things like cables
or chains on your mechanical mesh.
There are a couple of useful functions that help you get some dynamic movement.
So there's the local chain dynamics function, which will apply a sort of physics effect
to a chain of bones just using maths.
And there's the add jiggle function that simulates on just one element of the rig, which might
be a bone or a control rather than an entire chain of bones.
And it essentially uses a spring interpolate node to try and reach a target, whilst also
allowing you to add a delay and damping on its movement.
So it looks like it's jiggling as the rest of the mesh is moving.
Taking a look at some useful control types here, depending on what type of control you
create, you can actually give it different limits and force it to move in different ways.
So we have a mechanical arm here that's been set up.
And for this yellow control here, if we were to select it, you'll see that we can't
rotate in either the y or z axis, or can only rotate in the x axis.
And that's because for this type of control, we've set it to be a rotator.
That means it only has rotation, or it only has the possibility to rotate.
And under the settings here, we're actually able to give it some minimax settings.
So if you were to activate minimax for x and y, sorry, for y and z, and to set them both
at zero, that would limit the movement so that it can't move in those axes.
And you can only move in the open one.
You can also change this to a position, for example, if you wanted to only have translation
values, which can also be very handy.
Now something else that has a slightly more complex setup is a float control here.
If I just zoom in, you can see that as we move this float control down, this claw opens
up, and as we move it back, it closes.
And that's because we're essentially converting the transform information, or the float that
comes out of the movement of this control, into rotation information for these two claw
bones.
And in utilizing these different control types with their min and max settings, you can quickly
get something moving in a mechanical way, when you're locking down the different axes
in which it shouldn't be able to move.